bonsoir édition spéciale des u7 8
politique en ce 8 décembre la rédaction
vous propose un débat dans le cadre de
la campagne du second tour en ile de
france avant de débuter je vais juste
prendre quelques instants puisque vous
nous avions nous vous avions annoncé
depuis plusieurs jours ce rendez vous
pour vous permettre d'écouter les
candidats échanger sur leurs
propositions david douillet pour les
républicains benoît hamon pour les
socialistes avait notamment donné leur
accord
hier soir david douillet a choisi de
décommander en raison d'un problème
d'emploi du temps de dernière minute une
annulation entraînant ce matin le
retrait de benoît hamon se sont donc ce
soir des colistiers des porte paroles
qui vont participer au débat
contrairement à ce que vous nous avions
initialement annoncé othman naciri
porte-parole candidats de la liste de
valérie pécresse nous rejoindra dans un
instant bonsoir ali rabais je regrette
le directeur de campagne du parti
socialiste et bonsoir à philippe
chevrier vous êtes bien présent vous
avez annoncé que vous êtes bien présent
peut-être de discipline du front
national derrière vallerand de
saint-just vous connaissez les règles
tant parole est chronométré pour une
égalité de traitement nous allons
essayer au cours de la prochaine demi
heure de parler de plusieurs thématiques
transports éducation notamment à tout
d'abord j'aimerais vous faire réagir sur
les différents chiffres on va le revoir
ces différents chiffres notamment pour
l'ile-de-france et puis ensuite
concernant l les yvelines on notera dans
les yvelines que la liste de valérie
pécresse fait mieux qu'au niveau
régional et que les scores du ps et du
front national dans les yvelines sont
beaucoup plus proches que dans
l'ensemble de l'île de france a les
rabais pour le parti socialiste
aujourd'hui l'heure est à l'union un
grand d'union de la gauche pour autant
ça ne veut pas dire que la région est
acquise parce que c'est pas mathématique
et sur comment bien sûr entre les deux
tours des électeurs se déplacent qui ne
sont pas venus voter au premier tour et
évidemment des rapprochements des
fusions de listes se sont opérés pour ce
qui concerne la liste de claude
bartolone avec celle d'emmanuel coste
d'europe écologie les verts est celle de
pierre laurent du front de gauche
et cette fusion s'est fait naturellement
puisque dès le soir des résultats dès
dimanche dernier
chacun des dirigeants des deux
listes éliminées au premier tour a
appelé à voter pour claude bartolone au
second tour et surtout les discussions
se sont engagées sur les programmes et
sur la composition des listes
tout cela aboutit très vite par une
fusion des listes donc nous nous
présenterons rassembler la gauche et les
écologistes pour conserver la région à
gauche et les électeurs vous suivre il
faut aussi avoir l'adhésion de la nina
les traditionnellement les électeurs se
rassemblent au second tour les états
majors se rassemble mais surtout les
électeurs le font également
nous avons dirigé ensemble cette région
pendant trois mandats utilement nous
avons par exemple mis en place le taf le
tarif unique pour le pass navigo dans le
cadre de l'alliance entre les
socialistes les écologistes et le front
de gauche
les franciliens savent ce qu'ils doivent
à la majorité sortante et quels éléments
du bilan
ils doivent à la fusion des trois listes
déjà lors des mandats précédents
c'est le cas cette fois également nous
porterons des mesures audacieuses
ambitieuses pour l'île de france parce
que nous devrons rassembler
philippe chevrier dans les yvelines le
front national qui est à peu près de 19
% 18 % en ile-de-france c'est mieux que
qu'en 2010 sans précédent scrutin mais
c'est moins malgré tout que dans les
autres régions l'ambition pour vous
aujourd'hui c'est d'avoir un score
suffisamment important pour peser dans
l'opposition le plus possible bien
entendu c'est difficile de regarder dans
la boule de cristal mais moi ce que je
pense c'est que les électeurs de dupont
aignan ont tout intérêt à aller voter
pour le front le candidat du front
national parce que franchement quand on
regarde les programmes c'est exactement
une chose c'est plus qu'une question de
personne d'ego et c'est donc à partir du
moment où la liste dupont aignan n'est
plus présente je pense que les électeurs
vont se reporter massivement sur la
candidature de valente saint-just donc
il ya au moins ça je pense que
l'électorat socialiste va être un petit
peu découragé quand même des tractations
qui se sont en paquet en nord pas de
calais est maintenant dans l'est
je pense que certain nombre d'entre eux
vont être un peu écoeuré de ce qui se
passe et pour moi être tenté par le côté
assez sociale il faut bien le dire du
programme du front national donc les
arrangements quand il fallait le
programme social du front national parce
que nous on sait si le front national
arrive à la tête d'une région ce qu'il
fera des milliards d'euros de budget
notamment des franciliens c'est pareil
en nord pas de calais en région paca les
politiques antisociales du front
national on a pu les expérimentés dans
les communes qui l'ont dirigé y qu'il
dirige
c'est l'exclusion des chômeurs des
cantines scolaires c'est un certain
nombre de mesures d'augmentation des
tarifications pour les familles
notamment les plus modestes
donc j'espère pour les franciliens pour
les électeurs de nord pas de calais
picardie ainsi que pour les électeurs de
provence alpes côte d'azur qu'ils
n'auront pas à subir un mandat entier
d'un exécutif front national sur les
affaires d'euros pour 12 ans fait réagir
ensuite philippe chevrier tout même si
vous le but c'est que vous échangiez
aussi séparément ils réagir je vous dise
elle aura encore des reports de voix la
gauche unie en ile de france c'est un
potentiel de voix de 40%
très loin devant valérie pécresse qui a
plafonné à 31% ou l'annoncé bien plus
haut on a vu qu'en réalité son score et
notamment dans le département des
yvelines est relativement faible
je vous ferai remarquer d'ailleurs que
le département des hauts-de-seine a plus
voté valérie pécresse que le département
des yvelines dont elle est élue j'ai le
sentiment plus on connaît valérie
pécresse mon vote pourrait malgré tout
la gauche réunie fait un score honorable
dans les yvelines
le parti socialiste fait 4000 voix de
plus qu'aux élections de 2010 par
exemple dans un contexte évidemment
assez défavorables en ce moment mais ce
potentiel de voix ne peut être atteint
que si les électeurs se mobilisent de
toute façon vous l'avait dit pour ce qui
concerne nicolas dupont aignan les
résultats seront très serrés donc moi
j'invite vraiment fortement les
électeurs des villes populaires des
quartiers populaires des listes de
gauche quelle qu'elle soit à se
mobiliser très fortement puisqu'il peut
faire la décision au deuxième tour on
parlera d'abstention à la fin de cette
émission parce que l'abstention a été
forte en ile de france et dans les
yvelines plus qu au niveau national
d'ailleurs et puis si vous venez de nous
rejoindre vous précise que le
représentant de la liste de valérie
pécresse va nous rejoindre dans quelques
instants il est pour l'instant bloqué
dans la circulation mais nous sommes en
direct pour ce débat vous les voyez les
chiffres de l'abstention justement sur
notre secteur
petit micro-trottoir à présent on va
parler des différents points de
programme et nous sommes allés demander
aux électeurs tout simplement ce qu'ils
attendaient pour leur région les
parkings gratuits près des gares et et
des bons transports en commun ça serait
certainement bien pas grand chose
actuellement moi j'attendrais davantage
de sécurité quand même parce qu'il ya
vraiment des endroits j'aime pas
beaucoup être à la gare après huit
heures du soir
moi je prends ma voiture personnelle et
ses transports était plus facile et bien
j'avoue que je vais prendre à la
sécurité au collège moi j'ai des petits
enfants qui sont au collège on voit des
choses pas toujours terrible dans la
région qu'ils s'occupent plus des routes
déjà ça serait bien
il faut promouvoir les transports en
commun qu'on utilise moins la voiture
mais pour ça il faut des trains plus
fréquents et faut des parkings pour
ainsi aider traille fait un peu moins
cher aussi parce que l'air de rien
prendre le train c'est cheikh othman
astro le représentant de valérie
pécresse qui est candidat sur sa liste
dans les yvelines porte parole pour les
yvelines nous a donc rejoint pour ce
débat bonsoir à vous nous avons déjà
fait un premier tour de table et nous
avions arrivé sur les questions des
programmes sur les différents points de
programme on vient d'entendre les les
électeurs justement se prononcer sur sur
leurs différentes attentes on voit les
temps de parole aussi qui s'affiche bien
évidemment vous accuser un petit peu de
retard et c'est normal puisque vous
venez nous rejoindre et je voudrais
juste faire une remarque à présent c'est
concernant les compétences du conseil
régional ça concerne les transports
l'éducation l'apprentissage
aujourd'hui dans la campagne on a quand
même beaucoup entendu parler de sécurité
d'emploi aussi autonome l'impression que
le discours qui est offert par les
différends politiques et par vous ne
correspond pas véritablement avec les
compétences ensuite que vous allez
pouvoir les choses que vous allez
pouvoir réaliser concrètement on va
commencer tout de même avec philippe
chevrier puisque vous avez un peu plus
de retard et finalement menace rouge où
il passait la parole juste après du cube
alors sur l'apprentissage pas forcément
sur l'apprentissage mais sur le discours
aujourd'hui parce qu'on entend parler
les différents partis politiques vous
êtes sécurité c'est l'actualité qui veut
que
oui mais ensuite il n'y aura pas de
compétence pour la région la résidence
est évident mais pauvre puisque vous
parlez d'apprentissage nous on est à
fond pour un apprentissage à 14 ans où
le savez c'est pour nous essentiel dans
la vie de la région
ce qu'on veut en fait c'est dans ce
domaine c'est une carrément une
révolution culturelle
il faut cet apprentissage à 14 ans
devrait être en alternance c'est à dire
permettre également aux jeunes de
continuer à avoir une éducation sur au
moins sur les fondamentaux
est ce qu'on voudrait c'est que c'est la
formation professionnelle profite
beaucoup plus que maintenant aux
chômeurs aux gens qui en ont
véritablement besoin plutôt qu'à toute
une fraction de la population qui est
plutôt salariés cadres éventuellement
fonctionnaires et qui sont actuellement
les principaux bénéficiaires de ça on
souhaiterait favoriser aussi les
passerelles entre ces gens qui sont en
apprentissage par alternance et et
éventuellement l'enseignement secondaire
et l'enseignement supérieur et
éventuellement une qui est incertain de
passerelle avec conservation des acquis
à chaque niveau de progression de ses
jeunes voient la mission c'est vous avez
un petit peu devant celle à la suite de
ce débat où on parle d'éducation et
d'apprentissage en revient tout de même
à quai à ma question mais vous y avez
finalement a répondu avant le premier
tour on parlait beaucoup de sécurité
aujourd'hui pour vous il faut recentrer
le débat sur les différentes compétences
et vous préfériez aujourd'hui qu'on
parle plus des compétences que des
questions de sécurité
oui absolument ça me paraît plus
intéressant bon tout à l'heure vous avez
un petit peu cherché sur nos mères mais
il faut bien reconnaître quand même que
la population les a remerciés largement
est même plébiscitée dans les élections
suivantes donc sans doute que c'est pas
aussi anti sociales que vous voulez bien
le faire croire certains cantons manas
trouve vous passe la parole à présent et
sur le décalage peut-être qu'ils aillent
au premier tour et autour des questions
de sécurité est ce que c'est un peu
biaisé au 6e
souhaitant biaisé je ne crois pas parce
qu'on dit qu'effectivement la sécurité
n'est pas une compétence de la région en
réalité et les il ya même un budget
sécurité qui est votée par la région
je précise d'ailleurs que
malheureusement ce budget a été divisée
par cinq dans les dix dernières années
la région s'occupe des transports ce que
des lycées ce sont autant de sujets dans
lesquels la question de la sécurité doit
être vraiment prise en charge et moi je
défends les couleurs d'une candidate
valérie pécresse qui s'est vraiment
saisi de ce sujet depuis maintenant très
longtemps depuis plusieurs mois qui a
fait un ensemble de propositions
concrètes en matière de sécurité et bien
sûr les événements qu'on a connu nous
rappelle à tous l'importance d'aller au
vraiment mettre en place des dispositifs
nécessaires y compris sur les sujets de
la radicalisation de la lutte contre le
terrorisme et c'est malheureusement le
candidat socialiste en l'occurrence n'a
n'avait pas du tout anticipé ces
questions là puisque dans sa profession
de foi il n'y a même pas le mot sécurité
dans ses douze priorités
donc moi j'aimerais vraiment dire
qu'aujourd'hui il faut sortir de
l'angélisme du déni de la réalité
on a des problématiques majeures en
terme de sécurité et en particulier sur
la lutte contre le terrorisme on pourra
parler de ce qu'il faut faire en ce qui
concerne les fameuses fiches s il faut
absolument parler de la sécurité dans
les lycées données lissées ou
aujourd'hui la drogue est
malheureusement devenue un phénomène
endémique et à la question de la
sécurité dans les transports la
vidéoprotection sur laquelle on a pris
énormément de retard
donc aujourd'hui on a une région qui est
complètement défaillantes en matière de
sécurité depuis 17 ans il est vraiment
temps que ça change
la sécurité c'est le mot d'ordre dans
cet entre deux tours alors pour la liste
que vous portez c'est un thème majeur
vous a notamment lâché habitants et
c'est tout à fait légitime mais moi je
vous remercie de poser cette question
parce qu'effectivement c'est typiquement
le genre de sujet où on peut mesurer le
niveau d'opportunisme des candidats
quand ils sont en campagne électorale et
je pense que si le front national
progresse autant c'est notamment parce
que les candidats quand ils sont en
campagne le temps de quelques mois de
campagne électorale multiplié
propositions vont sur des terrains qui
ne les concerne pas engagent leurs
paroles sur des propositions qu'ils ne
tiendront pas ou sur deux sujets sur
lequel ils n'auront pas de compétences
en espérant pouvoir additionner les
voies pour essayer de l'emporter
le sujet de la sécurité en particulier
effectivement dans certaines des
compétences de la région on peut avoir
un lien avec la sécurité dans les lycées
dans les transports etc
claude bartolone vous ne trouverez pas
une déclaration un mot une proposition
qui ciblent a sorti de son chapeau le
lendemain des attentats pour essayer
opportunément de convaincre les
électeurs de voter pour lui
son programme et son discours est le
même depuis plusieurs mois il se
concentre sur les compétences de la
région il affirme par exemple qu'il
créera une police unique et des
transports pour permettre de me mettre
dans la même équipe coordonner tous les
agents aujourd'hui des différents
services des différents opérateurs qui
assurent la sécurité dans les transports
en commun claude bartolone s'engage sur
les domaines de compétences sur lesquels
il aura demain la main il ne s'engage
pas pour essayer d'additionner des voix
en essayant de séduire les électeurs du
front national je vais vous prendre un
autre exemple quand valérie pécresse la
candidate de la droite propose des tests
salivaires dans les lycées pour dépister
le cannabis par exemple c'est totalement
illégal
c'est même pas la question de savoir si
ça fait partie des compétences de la
région ce n'est pas légal donc ça ne se
fera pas si valérie pécresse est élu il
faut que les électeurs le sache
ça ne se fera jamais elle vous propose
des mesures qui stigmatisent par
ailleurs la jeunesse mais qui n'auront
aucune réalité concrète demain parce que
ça ne fait pas partie des compétences de
la région et que ce n'est pas légal je
termine en disant que je trouve que la
droite valérie pécresse ministre de
nicolas sarkozy est particulièrement
culotté d'oser évoqué la question de la
sécurité
parce que c'est une compétence
régalienne de l'état et que l'état sous
nicolas sarkozy sous valérie pécresse a
supprimé 13 mille postes de policiers
dans nos villes dans nos villages dans
nos écoles et notamment pour assurer la
sécurité des transports la gauche donc
si je trouve ça vraiment grotesque
d'oser aborder ce sujet d'en faire
quasiment l'étendard de ce second tour
si vous souhaitez réagir ensuite la
parole à philippe chevrier l'instant
très brièvement l après on parlera du
transport qui est une vraie compétence
importante pour tout à fait je la
verrais sécurité aussi la question
aujourd'hui c'est que monsieur bartolone
il est vraiment l'héritier d'une
doctrine arriérés du parti socialiste
ont entendu moustiques baptisé quand on
parle de la drogue dans les lycées on
stigmatise les jeunes on peut plus
évoquer ces sujets là s'en est tout de
suite taxer d'opportunisme
on va de sécurité voilà ait vraiment
compris les villes qui sont gérés
aujourd'hui par des équipes socialiste
je suis moi-même l'élu de trappes pour
une police municipale qui ne fonctionne
pas la nuit et dès que vous dites ça
vous est opportuniste ou vous utilisez
ces sujets la matière électorale
avec 11 milliards et demi d'euros de
budget la région doit prendre sa place
dans la chaîne de la sécurité
aujourd'hui sur tous les sujets ce sont
des sujets qui sont transversaux est
vraiment vraiment monsieur bartolone qui
a géré la seine saint denis dans des
conditions déplorables est vraiment très
mal placés pour aborder ces sujets là
sud de manière consensuelle non vraiment
je le dis
j'invite tout le monde à lire en détail
les projets et de voir qui est une vraie
cohérence dans l'équipe de valérie
pécresse sur ces sujets là sans aucun
opportunisme on n'est pas dans
l'agitation mais il faut qu'une prise de
conscience aujourd'hui qu'on se donne
les moyens la police régionale des
transports valérie pécresse propose de
la renforcer ce sont 300 policiers en
moins ces dernières années ça c'est une
réalité et ça n'a pas été décidée par le
gouvernement précédent
philippe chevrier et je reviens d'un
voyage c'est une ligne juste pour dire
treize mille postes de policiers en
moins pour aller chercher les
délinquants et les trafiquants de drogue
mais on nous propose là pour la région
ile-de-france des tests salivaires pour
aller chercher les consommateurs d'abord
ce n'est pas sérieux ce n'est simplement
pas ça j'étais contre le cannabis c'est
dé chelsea d'accord avec schalke se
vante j'ai vu oui mais j'ai vu dans
votre programme très ambitieux que
beaucoup de mesures est
nous ce qu'on voudrait en matière de
sécurité c'est avoir deux agents armés
par gare il ya 380 une gare en ile de
france on a on a chiffré ce que ça
coûtait et ce sera sans doute financées
par la baisse de la fraude en matière de
transport on veut aussi un centre
régional de vidéoprotection avec des
gens qui peuvent alerter en temps réel
les forces de l'ordre pour mettre fin
aux incidents et nous souhaitons
également une augmentation des effectifs
d'utilisation éventuelle de drones dans
des zones particulièrement sensibles ne
vois là et et maîtres et surveiller
également les abords des lycées avec des
caméras de la vidéoprotection et puis et
puis protéger les lycées par des
portiques à l'entrée
je referme cette question concernant la
sécurité vous avez parlé des transports
je vous laisse la parole philippe
chevrier les transports c'est un domaine
véritablement important pour les régions
qui gère elle est différente rien tout
simplement pour faire simple les
difficultés qui sont rencontrés au
quotidien par les voyageurs bien souvent
ils se tournent vers la région qui gère
tout ça philippe chevrier aujourd'hui
pour le front national
alors quelle est votre position sachant
que dans la question des transports il
ya aussi derrière tout ça la question du
grand paris
voilà alors exactement c'est à dire que
les voyageurs sont confrontés à des
difficultés comme vous venez de le dire
et qu'est ce qu'on leur propose on leur
propose le grand paris express qui est
un truc qui va circuler on sait pas où
dans le grand désert on va les ovations
sic ont été joués mais je pense que ce
soit ce qu'on va créer 70 gars je sais
pas où
sans doute donc grant west je ne sais
pas voilà enfin un truc qui va coûter
jusqu'à 32 milliards aujourd'hui mais
dans 30 ans tout sera fini je pense que
ce sera beaucoup plus important de 32
milliards
nous ce qu'on veut c'est moderniser le
rer a b c et d très simplement on veut
le pilotage automatique pour les rer b c
et d avec des vitres de protection on
veut doubler le tunnel châtelet et gare
du nord
un qui va donc améliorer les lignes b et
d
on souhaite aussi améliorer l'accès des
handicapés aux transports savait que va
le rendre s'ajuste a fait une
démonstration que dans certaines gares
proche d'ici les handicapés pouvaient
pas accéder au train et on veut aussi
très important une augmentation du
nombre de parkings de places de parking
dans les gares d'île de france dans la
grande couronne en particulier avec une
tarification combiné entre le parking et
le transport de manière à favoriser
enfin est-ce que les gens à orienter les
gens plutôt vers le train que vers la
voiture jusqu'à leur lieu de travail
votre mana sur vous pour la liste est
républicain modem et udf
moi j'aimerais dire que dans cette
élection vraiment valérie pécresse est
la seule qui ait pris les électeurs au
sérieux qui présente un projet parce
qu'on peut dire fer vale a effectivement
le catalogue de tout ce qu'on a envie de
faire
non quand faut-il le dire on trouve
l'argent c'est vraiment la seule et
j'invite vraiment tout le monde avait
sur internet voir son projet le volet
transports fait 19 pages et ses finances
et l explique où elle va trouver
l'argent
on a aujourd'hui une région plus de
joueurs de 17 ans on a une région qui
depuis 17 ans sous investis sur les
transports parce qu'elle préfère
privilégie son train de vie
ces dépenses de fonctionnement je vous
donnais à l'arraché très très précis en
98 quand la gauche prend la région ile
de france les deux tiers de son budget
vont à l'investissement et le tiers sur
le fonctionnement aujourd'hui celle
inverse
donc c'est vraiment le train de vie on
pourra détaillé là dessus parce qu'il ya
un vrai sujet sur la gabegie sur le
gaspillage de l'argent public sur les
transports il faut qu'on nous voulait
absolument le matériel ont l'un des
rames qui ont parfois plus de 40 ans 26
ans de moyenne d'âge
valérie pécresse a expliqué comment il
comptait faire cela on lit sans le
financement en trouvant des recettes
nouvelles en faisant un plan d'économies
de 400 millions d'euros
et c'est vraiment avec cela qu'on va
pouvoir remettre les les transports au
niveau sur le grand paris express
je n'apprécie pas dans la caricature de
ce projet qui est essentielle pour la
compétitivité de notre région il faut le
dire enfin on a le plateau de saclay qui
est un enjeu majeur pour la recherche et
le développement en ile de france est en
fait en france pour la france tout
entière et sans l'allier fameuse ligne
18 d'ailleurs qui fait encore débat à
laquelle malheureusement les europe
ecologie les verts notamment la région
s'ils s'y opposent s'oppose vraiment
fermement il faut qu'on arrive à sortir
des caricatures sur ce projet là qui
d'ailleurs est financé par l'état est
une compétence étatique qui n'a rien à
voir avec la région on peut rénover le
matériel roulant rénover les rams à une
vraie politique des transports très
ambitieuse avec la vidéosurveillance
partout partout je suis content
qu'aujourd'hui cette proposition ne
fasse plus débat
valérie pécresse a été caricaturé aussi
depuis des années à chaque fois qu'elle
parlait la vidéo protection de la police
des transports je suis content que
maintenant tout le monde s'y met mais
honnêtement on va pas régler des
problèmes mais que ceux qui les ont
créés on peut revenir sur la question de
la sécurité j'aurais courageuse sur la
question des transports
déjà pour corriger une imprécision
je vais étudier terme imprécisions quoi
être très sympathique
le stif syndicat des transports
d'ile-de-france est géré par la région
ile de france depuis 2006 auparavant je
vous rappelle que jean paul huchon était
due en 97 je vous rappelle qu'auparavant
c'était l'état qui gérait directement
avec les opérateurs la rénovation du
matériel roulant donc la compétence la
compétence de la région étaient nulles
en la matière
depuis il s'agit d'attraper le retard
très important qui a été pris en terme
de rénovation du matériel roulant
changement des rames vous savez les
rames à double niveau qui permettent
d'augmenter les capacités et la
régularité des trains également la
région ile de france a largement
contribué au rattrapage des retards qui
ont été pris je vous rappelle qu'entre
2002 et 2006 ce n'est pas la gauche qui
dirigeait la région certes mais pas le
gouvernement qui pouvaient investir
justement mettre les moyens nécessaires
les milliards nécessaires pour
renouveler le matériel et sa demande
évidemment puisque ce sont des milliards
d'euros qui sont en jeu du temps pour
faire venir ces rames les unes après les
autres pour remplacer ligne derrière par
lignes de et vers le matériel pour
permettre de gagner en régularité et en
capacité de déplacement pour pour les
franciliens
donc là dessus où l'on s'engage à
continuer le travail et claude bartolone
a pris l'engagement il ya déjà engagé
des discussions nécessaires avec le
premier ministre pour que dans le cadre
des partenariats entre l'état et la
région ile-de-france nous puissions
investir chaque année 800 mille euros
8,5 millions d'euros pardon pour rénover
le matériel roulant
et achevé en très peu de temps la
nécessaire le nécessaire renouvellement
du matériel roulant
je vous parle également de vous parler
d'autres propositions puisque a pas que
la question du matériel roulant
évidemment la mise à disposition des
transports 24 heures sur 24 c'est une
mesure qui figure dans le programme de
claude bartolone qui est parfaitement
finances et moi je reviendrai pas sur sa
veste grise et mickaël qui sont balancés
comme ça dans les émissions sur gabegie
il ya des mots comme ça des mots-valises
1 que la droite utilise régulièrement
aux gabegies laxisme et c'est qu'ils ne
veulent rien dire quand on regarde la
réalité des programmes et des bilans
mais la gauche elle propose de renforcer
la présence humaine dans les transports
après 21h pour assurer la sécurité
la gauche propose également ses lits et
insécurité transport milibris parce que
sur le tourne encore vous avez beaucoup
d'avant ce 1000e but sublime milliards
supplémentaires en grande couronne on
est en une dans les yvelines ici on sait
à quel point le soir c'est compliqué de
rallier son long domicile notamment
quand on habite loin dans les marches du
département des yvelines donc milliards
supplémentaires et ses bus s'arrêteront
à la demande pour pouvoir déposer les
habitants au plus proche de leurs
habitations et non pas dans des pubs
dans des arènes jusqu'aujourd'hui
notamment pour les femmes leur impose
des temps de marche important qu'on les
arrête pour une question de temps
justement on va voir les chronos les
différents temps de parole qui vont
s'afficher vous allez voir justement à
lire a b que vous avez pas mal d'avancé
puisque vous êtes presque à 7 minutes 4
minutes pour othman nas roues et
philippe chevrier quatre minutes 45
manas où avec un peu de retard mais on
leur explique puisque vous étiez absent
au tout début de ce2 ce débat chevrier
vous souhaitez réagir
oui oui sur le financement parce que
d'abord bon tout le monde s'est
brièvement qu'un petit peu de temps
j'aurais pas qu'on parle de l'abstention
pour terminer aussi d'accord notre
programme est financé j'invite
d'ailleurs tous les téléspectateurs
allaient voir notre programme sur le
site idf bleu marine
donc c'est très simple ils pourront le
constater en ce qui concerne plus
particulièrement les transports ce que
nous ce que nous voulions et que j'ai
décrit tout à leur coûterait 10 à 12
milliards
d'euros à comparer aux 30 milliards du
grand paris express
quant à la desserte du plateau de saclay
ça peut se faire très bien sans avoir
besoin de recourir à ce grand paris
express
donc voilà ce que je voulais dire par
rapport au mirail facilement parler du
financement là moi je vais encore une
fois j'aimerais que chacun voit les
postures qui évolue dans le temps en sur
ab nous explique la région fait ce
qu'elle peut écrire encore lui laisser
du temps ça fait 10 ans effectivement il
a dit ça fait dix ans que la région
s'occupe des transports et elle s'en
occupe
mal donc je ne vois pas pourquoi si ça
n'a pas avancé en disant pourquoi ça va
avancer tout à coup de main avec
monsieur bartolone j'ai plutôt tendance
à croire que ce sera le contraire sur
les financements c'est strictement la
même chose j'entends que certains ne va
demander à l'état de débourser 800
millions d'euros par an si l'état avait
cet argent là et ça se saurait d'une
part d'autre part moi je sais que ce
genre de promesses on les connaît son un
vécu avec monsieur hollande vie d'une
poche puis je pense que monsieur
bartolone demain vous videz l'autre et
on aura une augmentation d'impôts
ensuite parce que son programme n'est
pas financé ouvrir les transports 24
heures sur 24 une heure de métro en plus
toutes les nuits ces 200 millions
d'euros par an monsieur bartolone est
incapable de nous dire vu qu'il ne veut
pas faire d'économie vu que sa gestion
les quand même une question de
gaspillage je suis désolé de le dire il
faut quand même que les électeurs le
sache et puis ça rejoint la question de
l'abstention comment vous voulez vous
intéresser les électeurs un scrutin
quand on sait que la gestion socialiste
s'est par exemple des subventions
absolument sûr surréalistes ses trois
cent mille euros pour une piste cyclable
au chili ces soixante quinze mille euros
pour sauvons le colonialisme c'est le
clientélisme je suis désolé de le dire
et le choix qui est posée aujourd'hui
aux électeurs il est extrêmement clair
est-ce qu'on continue avec cette gestion
là alors voilà les 1000 le plan bus pour
les 1200 en grande couronne sud est de
le dire que ça fait des années qu'on
réclame s'arrête c'est récupérer mais il
faut que les acteurs fassent un choix
clair et malheureusement le seul
bulletin de vote pour changer dimanche
c'est valérie pécresse est la seule qui
peut l'emporter face aux peurs sur la
création de l'abstention avant dehors
vous redistribuez la parole un
micro-trottoir allez vous voter
justement dimanche êtes vous convaincu
par les différents candidats sur votre
région voici vos réponses de vie
évidemment ça c'est important quand on a
le droit de voter donc autant le faire
normalement oui depuis que j'ai 18 ans
j'ai pas raté un seul vote donc pas le
droit de vote c'est pas pour rien
non moi personnellement je sais pas si
tu sais pas pour qui voter donc ça va
allez tous bien sûr que je vais voter
dimanche
c'est un droit je dirais même que ça
devrait être un devoir parce que des
gens qui sont morts pour ça euh oui
parce que c'est un devoir civique
non franchement non on votre prono pour
rien faire alors on n'a pas vu
d'amélioration un pas vu de changement
alors du coup s'est pas loupé
pour moi c'est important à chaque fois
je vote je trouve qu'être ça c'est un
devoir de citoyen bien sûr c'est un
devoir citoyen c'est important de voter
quand même pas tout le temps qu'on a la
parole plus d'un électeur sur deux n'est
donc pas aller aux urnes il ya donc une
réserve de voix pour chacun des
électeurs on va revoir les chiffres de
l'abstention sur la france sur l'île de
france et sur les yvelines
l'ile-de-france mauvais élèves les
yvelines qui s'en sortent finalement pas
trop mal mais en france on a tout de
même voté un petit peu plus philippe
chevrier le message aux abstentionnistes
un électeur sur deux a boudé est très
simple quand on voit ce débat là ce soir
comme d'ailleurs d'autres débats rejouer
très bien que la gauche et à droite se
renvoient la responsabilité de la
situation soit d'ailleurs de la nation
soit de la région soit de toutes deux
tailleurs de tous les organismes
collectif que nous avons et il n'y a
qu'un seul choix maintenant on a essayé
la gauche on a essayé la droite faut pas
rester à la maison
il faut aller voter il faut aller voter
front national voilà le message que
j'adresse aux gens qui sont restés chez
eux au premier tour puisqu'on parle de
l'abstention peut peut-être mentionné la
commune de trappes 69% être d'abstention
et le front national qui fait figure de
cette deuxième partie deuxième formation
dans cette commune du coup l'abstention
plutôt tendance à vous profitez c'est
comme ça qu'il faut voir
non pas du tout c'est lui non non c'est
un fait le contraire voulu me faire
réagir
non on constate d'ailleurs à chaque fois
que la station régresse que nous
grimpons d'ailleurs vous avez vu
d'ailleurs dans le nord pas de calais et
en paca ça a été le cas
l'abstention a régressé et on a
progressé non non pour vous il ya des
réserves de voix en ile-de-france
montant de votre formation politique
parmi les abstentionnistes oui et je le
disais tout à l'heure parmi les
électeurs de dupont aignan est sans
doute peut-être parmi les électeurs de
gauche qui peuvent être écoeuré de ce
qui se passe dans dans les trois
territoires où la gauche se retire manas
sera belle aussi j'ai tous les deux à
attraper dans cette commune d'ailleurs
où l'abstention a atteint les 60 9%
vouloir des droits aux absentionnistes
aujourd'hui que je comprends qu'on n'est
pas forcément envie de s'intéresser au
débat politique que je ne crois pas du
tout que le front national soit une
solution d'ailleurs dans cette élection
régionale en réalité le front national
ne peut pas l'emporter donc voté front
national c'est aider le parti socialiste
à l'emporter et je crois que c'est
malheureusement le pari simic qui est
fait par le parti socialiste comme
d'habitude comme dans d'autres élections
et ça c'est vraiment quelque chose qui
est très très préoccupant est vraiment
vraiment con si on va arriver à la fin
de ces thèmes très consiste à juger les
candidats sur leurs actes et pas
simplement sur leur parole et la gestion
de monsieur bartolone en
seine-saint-denis ya un rapport de la
chambre régionale des comptes que
j'avais tout le monde à lire emplois
fictifs gaspillage cabinet pléthorique
du président est vraiment là dessus
c'est toute la gestion dont on ne veut
pas vraiment valérie pécresse est une
candidate intègre qui s'est engagé à se
consacrer exclusivement à ce mandat là
et j'avais tous les acteurs à lui faire
confiance dimanche allait rebondir
m'abaisser à jouer à ce petit jeu
j'observe par contre que le petit jeu
malsain justement qui que le mp joue en
particulier dans ce département et même
dans ce territoire puisque vous parlez
trappe qui consiste à tenir le discours
du front national a toléré en son sein
des éléments qui ont un discours
objectivement racistes et xénophobes
islamophobes sur les réseaux sociaux
notamment je vais vous donner deux
exemples 1 2 3 et âmes et 20 secondes
alors 120 salir la première à jour maire
de belvès en couleur me répondent qu'ils
relayent les tweets de marine marion
maréchal-le pen
le deuxième adjoint au maire de saint
cyr l'école qui a des propos racistes
également sur les réseaux sociaux
la deuxième de liste d'autres menaces
rattrape qu'il a choisi comme numéro
deux de sa liste et qui une élue
aujourd'hui front national au conseil
municipal de trappes
vous voyez ce petit jeu là qui consiste
justement à éluder les enjeux de
triomphe il sert à 3 c'est inadmissible
et ça aboutit à ce que le front national
progresse y compris dans des villes
comme trappe et l'ump fini troisième à
moins de créer votre ville mesure avait
moins de 15% et pécresse à -15% avec
autres menaces aux candidats
c'est clairement un élément de bilan
politique menée par l'ump le manteau
phrase tout est heureusement que le
front national monte et aide le parti
socialiste voilà c'est la conclusion de
ce débat je vous remercie a trouvé trois
d'être venu en tout cas débat qu une
demi heure mais nous souhaitions vous
proposez l'occasion d'entendre les
différents candidats avant de faire
votre choix pour le second tour
n'oubliez pas d'aller voter bien
évidemment est dimanche et puis nous
reviendrons sur ses résultats dès lundi
dans une édition spéciale à 18h très
bonne soirée